I want to turn in the phone lines right
now this man show has all the Emmys and
I'm not lying part of the reason why is
because of him and he's one of my
favorites Michael Wilbon back here on
the Rich Eisen show from pardon the
interruption how are you Michael Grich
I'm good man how are you I'm doing well
you know when the Cubs and Maddon parted
ways I'm like you know who can I talk to
to find out honestly
this is Bart I'll always love talking to
you you know you know that but I wanted
to get you on and say your floors yours
what what what happened here and and our
Cubs fans fine with it Michael my big
we're okay with it yeah I mean it look
Joe Maddon is forever gonna be serenaded
hugged applauded wherever he goes in
Chicago whenever he's there that's not
and that's done that set in stones he
did something that hadn't been done in
more than a hundred years it was great
and the four years were great the five
years all of it it's a well may not I
don't know the Cubs have had a better
five-year period certainly not in my
life and I'm getting old and I don't
know that in the last 75 did it probably
in the 30s 1930s the cousin of the World
Series I think in 30 to 35 and 38 I
think so that would have been a great
period okay where 80 years ago so they
reached the point rich which was clear
these last two years was the team wasn't
responding in a way that feel Epstein
thought was I don't know commensurate
with the talent on board they just they
hit a wall late each year and they want
to win one more and I understand that
and it was clear the team wasn't
performing up to that level and so
there's going to be a casual young man
there's no question about that
is Joe the only person I blame and of
course not the manager or coach never is
but but but this is ok this is ok it's
ok with most club fans I know right we
all text and talk all the time is there
some Cubs fan text chain and every club
fans life and I certainly have a
hmm and nobody was screaming bloody
murder I mean there were some people
more upset than others but this sort of
had to happen and now it's on with who
is it that the Theo Epstein and the
brass thinking get that extra bit of
distance out of the cuffs they didn't
get haven't gotten since 16 and for my
money and I know that David Ross is a
guy that you know what have they been
missing since 16 David Ross in that
Clubhouse we're it matter the same as a
if he's a manager as a player no it
won't be the same but maybe I don't know
maybe he can find that extra spark maybe
he is that spark
but I also Joe Girardi you just
mentioned I mean Girardi is a Chicagoan
in an inter rd you know a northwestern
guy what am i a wildcat and intimately
familiar with the Cubs the franchise
really how that whole thing operates how
it works so I you know and George
already has done this been there done it
and I'm one of those people who thinks
that there's a the element one of the
elements missing is a certain edge and
whoever can provide as I'm down with but
I think if you ask me who I would hire
jarate
if you told me that Girardi didn't want
to do it and they hired David Ross fine
but I Girardi is the name that pops up
for me oh I think he'd do it I think you
just got me would you might love a 3-1
to area code on his cellphone Michael I
mean so I know you know we you know
Joe's got that in him I mean I you know
I don't know Joe well I know I'm to say
hello and how you doing we talked about
some stuff at school and as alums and
and what's going on in the area and he
yes that is in him and I think that's
what one of the many reasons why it
works Michael Wilbon here on the Rich
Eisen show let's change some gears here
Michael other than football what's been
lighting up a phone line right here on
this show is the conversation borne out
of the California Fair pay to play act
that yeah that governor signed into law
here allowing collegiate athletes in the
state of California starting in 2023 to
be able to hire an agent for endorsement
purposes and make money off their name
like Miss an image and as you know there
has been a human outcry from the
n-c-double-a and also certain pac-12 Big
Ten commissioners and so on and so forth
that say it's the end the sky is falling
where do you stand on the subject it
should be the end the end of the
n-c-double-a as we know it get out
you've been Barney Fife for 4050 years
get out you how many chances if you had
did get out and I'm glad this is signed
into law I'm glad it's law I will talk
so people you know people still it's
amazing people have more information at
their fingertips than ever and yet
people are dumber than ever about
certain things that they don't want they
put their fingers in their ears they
don't want to hear so let's give a real
strong example of some how this could
happen let's say a the top female golfer
at UCLA decides that she wants to now
put a shingle out and she can give
lessons she can teach she can go to
school and go to UCLA and play golf and
also give some lessons and people are
willing to pay the going around what's
what's going rate 80 bucks an hour
something like that and they decide
people decide they want to go to this
young lady and pay her and she makes a
couple of grand a month that might be a
little ambitious but she can do that
well now she can before she couldn't
that's what likeness is as well that's
what it includes
if a player wanted to see if a player
wanted to sell his or her game-worn
Jersey to an alum after a game so we
have a little auction they could do that
it doesn't mean the school or the state
is paying the player the student people
are so dumb about these things I I'm not
just in favor of it it should happen a
long time ago and if the n-c-double-a
can't get its arms around it or can't
figure out a way to morph into an
organization that can live with this
kind of change it has got us if it's
happened in California rich is going to
happen in Florida and Texas going to be
far behind
No
what happened all over the place and
like Richard Sherman and draymond Green
and others let the n-c-double-a just
deep-six it let it go away
someone else will come along with an
idea there are very smart capable people
who managed to create models that manage
much more difficult things than this
well I don't let let them come right out
of the woodwork and start planning it at
the n-c-double-a can't get its act
together please be gone I'm with you on
that Michael that said I would couple
things number one great Barney Fife
reference just great any time anybody
can come on and conjure up an image of
Don Knotts it's all good it's all good
Michael and if people don't know there
is Google unlike the time when Barney
Fife was was ruling America that's
number one number two the the unintended
consequence however that I'm I'm
thinking about while also pounding the
table that I have here in front of me as
strongly as you just did on the phone
right here Michael Wilbon in the Rich
Eisen show is what about the buddy
Garrity z-- of the Friday Night Lights
world now suddenly bringing in all kinds
of cash absurdly large absurd numbers of
dollars into the pockets of players that
would then send them to institutions of
higher learning at which there's no
learning so what about that idea that
suddenly now you're letting out yeah
it's certainly it's certainly gonna
exist rich I'm not gonna stick my head
in the sand on that but it's already
existed I mean some schools have already
had advantages over others and some
schools have been put on in the
n-c-double-a with a half-hour put people
on probation it didn't did it discourage
it it certainly if it if it stopped it
if it served as a deterrent it didn't
discourage everybody I mean that's any
system is going to have people looking
at it to find loopholes I mean we know
that we just like tax law in the United
States of America
unless isn't this isn't unique going to
be unique to intercollegiate competition
but you you do the best you can I mean
there are people you know there are
let's face it there are young Mark Cuban
type minds out there who may say okay
here's his here's the way that this
should go here's a system I've got one
you know ever there'll be people like
this they already are let's find them
and I'm not so worried about the
exceptions there look they're going to
be exceptions they've been exceptions
the n-c-double-a it wasn't just
exceptions sometimes it ran rabid so
let's get rid of that cancer first and
again if the n-c-double-a can come up
with a way to manage this fine then they
can throw their hat in the ring with
others but just to think that this is
not going to happen in the n-c-double-a
oh poor n-c-double-a I I'm way past that
point the n-c-double-a should have been
proactive in these sorts of ways decades
ago and was it Michael Wilbon here on
the Rich Eisen show from pardon the
interruption and so much more the NBA is
coming back in just a couple weeks right
now and it's as wide open as anybody can
remember how do you predict this season
how is it possible to predict it Michael
it is it and and and as wide open as
ever is the best way to describe it
because every sport has its you know its
own culture you know the NHL has one in
which the regular-season points leader
the number one seed if you will often
goes down in the first round I mean it's
just no surprise we've seen that with
the Penguins we've seen that I got up
sitting with the Capitals two or three
times I've seen it with my Blackhawks in
recent years like the last time I think
on the planet they were the number one
seed and you know and that that's that
culture you know and pro football
obviously you can go worse to first in a
division you know we see it all the time
a draft and a free agents a free agency
period can change NFL team overnight in
the NBA you've got two or three
favorites and the question of the season
is can anyone not these two
well something go wrong and we don't see
them in the spring and every sports got
its own its own culture and and that's
the nba's but but we're looking outside
of that now because it's not three or
two although it's sometimes a false
narrative last year was oh it was a
people thought it was a one horse story
the Warriors and that's not how it
turned out but if we're looking at we
got to be looking at both teams in LA no
no I think the Lakers are gonna have
more trouble getting themselves together
then a lot of people think but we're
looking at the Clippers and Lakers I
think we're looking at Utah I don't know
I think Denver needs another year
seasoning but we're certainly looking at
them I mean you can go you can go seven
or eight there are people I talked to
Isiah Thomas and Kenny Kenny Smith two
guys who God knows if you look up the
tree if you look up the definition of
traditional point guard rich
those guys were it and they won
championships plural I mean they they
won four NBA championships and college
championships and both those guys think
the Rockets can get themselves to that
point with Harden and Westbrook and I
don't think that but the Rockets are
certainly going to be in play I think by
the end of the year the Warriors will be
in place we're talking how many teams
about his names only in the left that's
correct right
and so I haven't mentioned Portland I'm
into San Antonio I think San Antonio's
gonna be a team that sort of rebounds a
little bit and starts entering its way
back up but it's going to be hard this
year so you've got so many teams and I
think Philadelphia in the East and I
don't want to discount Boston but I
think Philadelphia so there's so many
teams this is a new way of looking at
the NBA and I think it's I think it's
great I mean I don't know what people
could want you got stars spread all over
the lead you got places like Dallas
where you got young stars who are going
to be back in effect so you know with
the unicorn healthy at some point again
and and and Dante so I just I I can't
wait to see it I don't know what to make
of it there is 11 I don't know what to
make of it is I think it's going to be a
different kind of fun that we have to
look so many different places
to try and figure out who's doing what
in the NBA well I mean I'll bite on the
whole Lakers thing since that is
obviously the fascinating team because
it involves LeBron and his closing
window that we're all assuming is
closing and the fact that last year they
didn't have the shooters and then he
didn't stay healthy and we all saw what
happened now here comes Anthony Davis
I'm wondering why you think they're
gonna have trouble putting it all
together is it still the outside
shooting to you Michael
no no not account another Cunha is you
know they they got enough of that I
don't think the Lakers are gonna lack
anything I just think it's these things
don't happen overnight we've seen every
you know so many times people make big
changes and then folks wonder why
they're not you know running the table
by Christmas well because it doesn't
work that way
so even LeBron is talking about running
things through Anthony Davis you every
Davis despite where he can play on the
floor still a big and you you're gonna
run things through him which fine is
great but it's that has to be taught it
has to be learned it has to be accepted
it has to be perfected and while you're
doing all that suppose Paul George gets
back in that lineup after five or six
games and the Clippers who don't have to
do all that they're there they're
bringing two guys two great players and
know how to play without the ball into a
forty eight win team and so suppose they
don't take that long suppose they take
to like mid November and they're rolling
and suppose you finish fourth or fifth
or sixth in the West and you and the
team you have to face in the first round
is Utah or a Denver how about Golden
State or Portland nobody hears the truth
of the matter despite all the doom and
gloom forecast around Golden State
they're gonna start the season with
three all-stars on the court and you're
gonna get a fourth back how many teams
out there playing against the Warriors
gonna have four all-stars on the court
oh boy by March 1st so III do do I think
the Lakers are gonna get some sort of
box it's not like the Cleveland
Cleveland Browns but it is I mean people
want to talk to Cleveland Browns into
being good you're not going to
welcome to being good they got a they
got to play themselves into that and the
Lakers were supposed to be so great last
year is LeBron suppose he misses ten or
twelve games so density Davis who's been
injured most years misses some games how
are the Lakers going to be able to to
put all of this together and get it
together by win so do I think that the
Lakers will be good enough to win a
championship this year they clear they
could be but am I going to am I going to
bet on it
the first year with all this going on ah
you can tell I'm hesitant well rich and
I think I think it's probably gonna be
somebody else coming out of the way
Conference Finals maybe I can't wait to
see them but I don't think it's
automatic that there's gonna be like you
roll them out you say the names out loud
and they're gonna scare anybody to death
not in that conference I got I could
talk to you all day but I've got two
things I want to hit you before I let
you go Michael Wilbon first things first
how hot is this take I would just give
me a temperature how hot is this take
the Bears are better with chase Daniel
at quarterback how does that take I very
very scorching hot I don't believe it I
believe that James Daniel is great for a
couple games people forget so last year
you won on Thanksgiving Day right in
Detroit which is always a great win but
then they lost to the Giants they lost
the Giants even though he did some nice
things he kept them to overtime in that
game that was a game which Odell Beckham
wanted to put a touchdown pass to beat
the Bears
III don't believe that I don't believe
that I mean he did some things he does
right now that make you say that make
people go to that high take you know but
I don't believe in the long run he can I
want to see chase Daniels I don't want
to see him from one about three games so
the Raiders game in London this weekend
and he has to play the first game out of
the buy against New Orleans the Battle
of the backups he and Teddy Bridgewater
okay but they got to get true Biscay
back in there there certain things chase
Daniel can't do physically and Pat
throws he can't make any probably won't
try he can't use his legs like to Biscay
I you know I'm not that that defense by
the
looks to me it looks to me at this point
it's very early
it looks to me as ferocious as the 85
defense then though they did the oats Oh
6 defense with Urlacher and peanut
Tillman and Lance Briggs and all those
guys got to a Super Bowl this defense to
me seems even more frightening like I
think I've been part of the problem mr.
quarterbacks are physically afraid of
them that's happened before that
happened in 85 we don't see that anymore
because the rules don't allow it
except you watch their game last week it
looks like the Bears players and not
just Cleo Mack but it looks like they
were throwing guys out of a saloon in
listeners picking them up and moving
them because they are and so that to me
is the attraction of that team that's
always the attraction of a Bears team we
don't ever have quarterbacks we can
depend on you know I mean it looks like
Steve fuller in the 84 bear whoever was
coming off the bench when Jim McMahon
was hurt for the 85 and 86 Bears I don't
know if they have enough to get there
but I
god bless Jeff Daniel last week I ain't
rolling with that the whole season okay
and then last one for you Michael we saw
your tweet the other day about who was
not awake for the big gnats come back
tonight's game one first pitch is 20
minutes later than it was for the game
that Tony Kornheiser could not stay
awake for what's the over-under and the
number of innings Tony will stay awake
for tonight Michael tonight oh it's late
it's late on the East Coast yeah imma
give him I'm gonna give him four innings
he can't help himself it's like it's
like no no I know but it's kind of like
the analytics here don't favor him so
it's just twice through the lineup and
he's out just like just like starters
and it's one of those if it plays out
more like an American League game
because there are homeruns and early
right pitching changes he walk then we
could take two under I mean you know
this is Tony I called his house and when
Carol answered the phone and she was
screaming hollering at the end of the
game to the quiz everybody it was
while affiliates didn't have a horse in
the race I'm calling him in Washington
DC and I said okay this you're awake
that means he's got to be away cuz he
goes no no no I know got a nap and I
said and here's what the since I've
never heard she nobody wakes him up but
you don't even want to bother with that
and she said I think I'm gonna wake him
up and I said no and she did wake him up
rich this this to me so the team has
been back here I don't know what
fourteen years something like that right
this was the this was the biggest night
in the Nationals history in the in in
Washington time I'm not going back to
Montreal and in terms of baseball of
Washington says Walter Johnson at the
league of nations that's done so I just
I promised in that Tweety's you know I'm
gonna pound him yes yesterday
you know mark Walter the Dodgers owner
principal owner is a Northwestern guy
okay in part he's a Midwestern guy he's
what he's a wildcat Wow have to pop it
up man if we got Joe Girardi back to the
news Marc Walter the Dodger owner
northwestern law school and a trustee as
I am and so I've gotta know Mark and his
wife and he's you know Bulls fan and I
mean you know this is this is great so I
can't say I don't have any interest in
the game and if I got him Earvin Johnson
I've heard a little bit who is I've
already him and worked with him for
years and just you know was just willing
to celebrate a milestone birthday so I
can't say I have no skin in the game
it's going to be a little I don't know
dicey try to navigate that one living in
a house with a Washingtonian and having
people in high places with the Dodgers
who are pretty close to well I I'm
be real quiet during this series you
send on my best to mr. Tony you're the
best to Michael I love chatting with you
you take care of yourself rich thanks
for having me man yes you know Tony you
sit stay awake yes do it you got it you
do it that's Michael Wilbon at real Mike
will bond on Twitter for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
- 39 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app